[Music]
do anything I'll do whatever it takes
to
[Music]
what's happening everybody I'm Dave
Ruben this is the Ruben report it's
December 7th 2023 we're live streaming
on Rumble locals and YouTube Share
subscribe tap the notification Bell and
feel free to join us after the show for
a postgame Ruben report. locals.com
which is is where we'll be taking some
questions from today and as a reminder
the new Dave ruin. store is up right now
I think we've got an
image is there an image over here
somewhere there we go we got an image
hoodies hats mugs and more could there
be anything better for your family for
Hanukkah for Christmas for chrisa k
quanica whatever you do we've got this
stuff for you happy Hanukkah to all the
Hebrews out there of course tonight is
night one of Hanukkah Hanukkah is the
ancient story of the Hebrews the Jews
defending their land the Judean Hills uh
from the Greek Invaders of course the
Judean Hills are in what we now call
unfortunately the West Bank but that is
part of Israel to the dismay of Rashida
Talib and ilhan Omar and the rest of the
Hamas caucus uh we're going to put out a
video I think a little bit later today
explaining a bit about Hanukkah that
hopefully we can get to the Hamas caucus
so that when they're congratulating and
welcoming and telling people oh happy
Hanukkah later today they'll understand
it's a little bizarre because they're
also saying that the Jews shouldn't live
in that place while you're wishing them
uh you know a festive holiday season uh
but today uh we will be covering the
final debate which was last night the
final Republican debate uh I do want to
be upfront yes they are the candidates
apparently although there's really only
one person up there who's truly running
for president and then there's an orange
man that he's running against we'll get
to that in just a second uh but I do
want to be uppr I did not watch the
debate live I was uh out to dinner with
my team here and I've got a buddy who is
moving to Florida who was looking for
houses all day yesterday with his
girlfriend moving to the free state of
Florida leaving an undisclosed Blue
State and I wanted to show him a good
Floridian time so it is only this
morning that I got caught up on all the
clips and all the viral stuff and all
that we're just going to dive in and
then I want to at the end just kind of
lay out a little bit of what what really
is going on here because what really is
going on here has very little to do with
what happened uh at that debate last
night so why don't we just dive in but
well actually before we do how about an
ad somebody's got to pay the bills
around here guys I want to share
something truly exciting picture this an
investment opportunity that's been
quietly generating substantial income
outside the chaos of the stock market
this isn't your typical stock Bond or
option it's something bigger something
that's been delivering incredible
returns we're stepping into an
unprecedented energy bull market akin to
the booming 70s where the demand for oil
is skyrocketing think about it China's
hunger for energy the US replenishing
reserves and global global conflicts
altering the oil landscape with Russia's
exports disrupted and OPEC scaling back
oil supply is plunged precisely when
demand is soaring predictions are in
brace yourself for much higher oil
prices Global demand is set to hit a
staggering 101 million barrels per day
driving prices and royalties to new
heights but here's the game changer oil
and gas royalties picture collecting
income without the roller coaster ride
of drilling exploration costs or
workforce management you just sit back
and reap the rewards of oil sales now
the golden opportunity we're talking
about a peran basin royalty stream the
crown jewel of oil reserves Warren
Buffett's wager to cool 12 billion on
this region and listen to this while
stocks bonds and crypto stumbled this
royalty stream sword with a staggering
149% returns in 2022 alone quarterly
Revenue growth boasting an astounding
77% and over 42 mil in Revenue over the
past year consistency is key right well
this royalty stream has been serving up
monthly dividends uh monthly dividend
payments without fail since
2276 consecutive months of steady income
so listeners imagine being part of this
success story don't let this opportunity
slip by and step into an investment
that's proven lucrative and ready to
fuel your financial future go to 2024
oil boo.com or click the link below and
get started today okay so let's just
dive right into the bait I'm going to do
a little bit of just kind of the drama
the fireworks the viral stuff then we'll
get into the substantive stuff and then
I'm going to lay out what I think is
going to happen for the next month until
we hit that Iowa caucus uh and then a
few other primaries that will happen
right after that let's start with uh VC
who I've you know I've had my
frustrations with VC but here he
basically just blows Nikki out of the
water this was really the viral clip of
the whole night I want to say one thing
about the tie to Ukraine if I may so for
foreign policy experience is not the
same as foreign policy wisdom I want
everybody at home to note that I was the
first person to say we need a reasonable
peace deal in Ukraine now a lot of the
neocons are quietly coming along to that
position with the exceptions of Nikki
Haley and Joe Biden who still support
this what I believe is pointless war in
Ukraine and I think those with foreign
policy experience one thing that Joe
Biden and Nikki Haley have in common is
that neither of them could even state
for you three provinces in eastern UK
Ukraine that they want to send our
troops to actually fight for look at
that this is what I want people to
understand these people have I mean she
has no idea what the hell the names of
those provinces are but she wants to
send our sons and daughters and our
troops and our military equipment to go
fight it so reject this myth that
they've been selling you that somebody
had a cup of coffee stint at the UN and
then makes 8 million bucks after has
real foreign policy experience it takes
an outsider to see this through look at
the blank expression she doesn't know
the names of the provinces that she
wants to actually fight for and there's
a puppet master right there the donors
the donors right there that are playing
about the Puppet Master hold okay credit
where credit is do be is right be is
right I you know and I'll tell you this
I don't think I can name three provinces
in eastern Ukraine either but I haven't
been calling for intervention in Ukraine
actually since the day this thing
started I've been going uh we got to
figure out what's going on here Putin's
got nukes blah blah blah I don't need to
make this about me but the point is that
Nikki and some of the more neocon or
hawkish foreign policy people have been
pushing us on this Ukraine thing
Congress and the Senate have been
endlessly funding it and it's like we
don't really know what's going on on the
ground we don't know where the money is
going remember when I had Rand Paul on
the show a couple months ago and he said
hey maybe we could fund some of this
stuff but could we at least just get
some receipts on what's happening with
our money and we cannot even get that so
her Blank Stare there uh that that ended
Nikki like I I think that just ended I I
think it it there was it was never
really real in the first place again I I
personally like her she is a lovely
woman she has been to my house for
dinner but he he just ended this thing
uh and speaking of ending ending this
thing uh Chris Christie then just uh
went after rebec just right after that
okay you say this you do this you do
this at every debate you go out on the
stump and you say something all of us
see it on video we confront you on the
debate stage you say you didn't say it
and then you back away and I want to say
I'm not done yet this
look is this man ising let me tell you
something this is the fourth debate the
fourth debate that you would be voted in
the first 20 minutes as the most
obnoxious blow hard in America so shut
up for a while I'm I'm going to respond
to
that I'll take that I want to say
something else we're now 25 minutes into
this debate
and he has insulted Nikki Haley's basic
intelligence not her positions her basic
intelligence she doesn't know regions
she wouldn't be able to find something
on a map that his three-year-old could
find look if you want to disagree on
issues that's fine and Nikki and I
disagree on some issues but I'll tell
you this I've known her for 12 years
which is longer than he's even started
to vote in a Republican
primary and while we disagree about some
issues and we disagree about who should
be president of the United States what
we don't disagree on is this is a smart
accomplished woman and you should stop
insulting so I'm going to take this I'm
going several times over so first of all
I think we just learned something from
Chris all right I don't want to spend
too much time on all this because you
guys know this is all a sideshow these
are not people who are going to be
president uh at all right but there were
a couple interesting things there the
12year line was kind of good the way he
hit VC on that uh but the thing about
Christy sort of being like don't insult
her intelligence well I will give BC
credit it was a good line it was a good
line name some provinces you want to
send all this money out there name some
Pro that's not going after her
intelligence that's going after her
competency or basically her
understanding of this region of the
world that they want to give hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars to
uh so okay we're just we're almost
through the the drama here's uh just one
more with a little a little Zinger first
of all Chris Christie also doesn't know
what provinces in eastern Ukraine he
actually want us to fight for Chris your
version of foreign policy experience was
closing a bridge from New Jersey to New
York so do everybody a favor just walk
yourself off that stage enjoy a nice
meal and get the hell out of this race
when it comes to n okay Zing he's fat we
get it fine now I want to get to some
sub some substantive stuff because one
of the things that came up and has
consistently come up
is that Ronda santis doesn't just say
the things that he's going to do he has
a track record of doing all the things
that he says and Nikki Haley accused
Ronda santis of not signing a bathroom
bill here in Florida meaning that it
would stop boys from going into girls
bathrooms uh take a look at this and
this shows how hypocritical Ron
continues to be when he was running for
governor and they asked him about that
he said he didn't think bathroom bills
were good use of his time you can go
look that up I signed a bathroom bill in
Florida so that's obviously not
true so the idea that you would say that
I was sign you didn't you killed it I
signed it I stood up for little girls
you didn't do it and there was this
going on I was actually just in South
Carolina some of the legislators told me
at the time there were boys going into
the girls that's the whole reason why
they did it and so they say when she
does that explanation that that doesn't
hold water and this is the upstate of
South Carolina I signed the bill I
protected the girl sou Carol did not you
know sou Carolina because okay putting
aside the little tit for Tad drama yes
Ronda santz did sign the bathroom Bill
she completely made that up here you go
I'm not going to read the whole thing
for you but it's hb1 1521 Ronda santis
signed it and it stopped boys from going
into girls bathrooms and girls from
going into boys bathrooms Nikki Haley
never signed such a bill so she flat out
lied and once again and and this is the
competency issue that DeSantis has just
saying the right thing and saying the
truth it doesn't go viral but I think
for those of us that actually care about
the truth and care about competency and
care about America we have to just stand
up and and reiterate when actual truth
is is presented on that stage uh here's
Dan santis going a little bit further on
Haley when it comes to women's sports
and I also say that biological boys
shouldn't be playing in girls Sports and
I will do everything I can to stop that
because it's the women's issue of our
time protect women sports I get this
yeah again it's quick but it's him
saying I've done it I've done it I'm the
one that signed the stuff right so they
she's saying okay I'll do it I will do
it when I'm president I'm GNA keep girls
out or keep boys out of girl Sports and
the santis again just I've done it and
in some ways maybe that should have been
desantis's tagline the entire time like
I've done it whatever you people are
complaining about I've done it and that
goes for VC Trump and and Christy too
every time they try to hit him he's done
it uh DeSantis then he you know he
doesn't go on the attack that often
because he's usually just defending his
record and laying out what his vision is
uh but you know there was this big
moment about a week and a half ago when
Nikki Haley said that she wanted to uh
un anonymize some people online meaning
if you have a burner account on Twitter
or just an anonymous account that we
should not allow for these accounts uh
she said that everyone should have to
have an ID with with these accounts uh
here's Dan santis going after her on
that but having said that I never said
government should go and require
anyone's name FAL she said I want your
name as president of the United States
her first day in office she said one of
the first things I'm going to
do
your am that's what she said you can
roll the tape she said I want your name
and that was going to be one of the
first things she did in office then she
got real serious blowback and
understandably so because it'd be a
massive expansion of government we have
Anonymous speech The Federalist Papers
were written with Anonymous writers Jay
Madison and Hamilton they they went
under pubus it's something that's
important and especially given how
conservatives have been attacked and and
and they've lost jobs and they've been
cancelled you know the regime would use
that to weaponize that against our own
people it was a bad idea said I'm not
man we just don't deserve the guy I mean
he's talking about the Federalist papers
and the importance of anonymous speech
and why it would be an expansion of the
federal government all those things and
Nikki just 100% lied we played you that
clip about two weeks ago when she said
she wanted the name so 100% she lied
there she did reference Bots as well
that there's another problem with Bots
and I've talked about this a million
times you guys get it there's a problem
there is some issue with having all of
these Anonymous counts that behave
horribly but that doesn't mean the
government has a right to take away
their free speech and there's a separate
issue about Bots and Ai and everything
so anyway he he just calmly lays it out
she just flat out lied I want to show
you one uh video this is from the
official Ronda santis account and they
put this up right before uh because all
for all everything I've shown you so far
Vette going after Nikki and Nikki and
Christy
defending none of it matters because
those three people BC Nikki and Christie
are not really running for president
they're doing whatever they want to do
for the rest of their careers and that's
just fine that's what politics is but
there is only one guy running against
Donald Trump trp in reality it's Ronda
santis and you may remember that I asked
him a little while back like how do you
get the ride or die Trump people and he
put this on his account right before uh
the debate what's your message to the
ride or die Trump people nobody in in
the United States in the Republican
party has delivered more on America
First policies and principles than me uh
if you look at illegal immigration but
we've banned Sanctuary cities we've
cracked down on human smuggling we even
sent illegal aliens to beautiful
Martha's Vineyard we've put our money
where our mouth is you talk about things
like China we've banned the purchase of
land by the CCP and its Affiliates in
our state we got rid of things like
confucious institutes and we cracked
down on their influence of universities
uh you look at what we've done for
expand second amendment rights with
constitutional carry look at what we've
done to fight against the woke agenda
whether it's fighting Disney involving
education or fighting this ESG movement
which is really bad for our economy and
for American families the way they're
going after domestic energy production
you want to talk about draining the
swamp there's one guy in this entire
country that's ever taken action against
Soros back prosecutors and that's me and
we've removed two of them from Office
who were not following the law and were
putting their political agenda over
Public Safety I cleared out the election
supervisors in South Florida when I
became Governor we' banned Zucker bucks
we' banned ballot heart harvesting we
have Universal voter idid and we even
have an election crimes police force in
state government which prosecutes voter
FR so we have the best election
Integrity in the entire country so I
think in terms of delivering on these
things nobody's delivered more than I
have and everything I promised the
voters I would do I've delivered on and
exceeded those promises and so you got a
guy like me going in there you know
you'll have two terms of somebody that
the people in Washington do not want to
up there the corporate press does not
want to see me up there and the
Democrats don't want to see me up there
because they realize I don't just say
this stuff in a campaign season when I
tell you I'm going to do something I
follow through and I do as Conor said to
me in the middle of that but he didn't
say anything funny up there and it's
like maybe that's where we're at As
Americans maybe that's the state of the
country in 2023 and we will get exactly
what we deserve but he didn't lie last
night and he doesn't lie on stage and he
is decent man and in that little clip
right there which is unedited that was
the that was one answer that he gave me
over the course of a minute and a half
he laid out what he's done and he has
done all of those things and he has
fought all of the right fights and
everything else so now I want to show
you one other thing it's not from the
debate last night but it is from uh
Donald Trump on with Shan Hannity two or
three days ago uh and Hannity asked
Trump what he thought of the DeSantis
Nome debate
well I saw one person on who I actually
had a very good relationship with but
I'm sure that it would end very quickly
I saw him in your debate the other night
and he's slick but he's got no facts you
know he's got no facts uh I thought he
did well considering you're talking
about gav yeah considering that he
didn't have the facts I thought he did
well you know he said we have the lowest
taxes in the country we have the
cleanest streets in the country withi
and I'm saying wait a minut you talking
about the same place I'm so over this
thing I'm so over this thing he says
everything and nothing at the exact same
time considering he didn't have the
facts he did well so what do you mean
because he lies about everything but his
suit fits right what what Trump means
and Trump likes that right Trump's a TV
guy so he is impressed when someone can
just lie and smile through the lie and
their hair is sliick back Trump does
like that he instead of he what he could
have done if you're up by 50 points Don
what you could do is be like you know
Ronda sanis did a nice job Rhonda
because Florida is a good place and
that's why I live there and that's why
all my children live there and that's
why all my grandchildren live there and
he was the best on Co and I think I I
just think I would make a for a better
president because I didn't get to finish
the job last time and I could he can lay
out a case for himself uh and he can
actually say some good things about the
santic which everyone knows would be
true and that would be honorable but I
know that that's not the the road that
he wants to go down instead it's I I I
think he did well you know he he's a
liar but I I think he did well you know
I think uh you know considering he
didn't have the facts and it's just it's
gross and it's boring boring and it's
tiresome and it is not going to resolve
anything and I think most people
actually know that I really do think
most people actually get it so we are
going to need someone who will tell the
truth we are going to need someone who's
going to say those are the things I'm
going to do and then go do them we're
going to need somebody who can staff
properly who can Bridge The Divide and
start bringing some of the disaffected
Liberals and there's an awful lot of
them right now or we can vote for
somebody that has the highest negatives
of anyone in in modern political history
and again I don't hate the guy I'm not
sitting here with Trump derangement
syndrome I freaking voted for the guy
last time but we are going to have to
make a decision and the choice is is so
obvious and I think most people know it
and I think that that's why Trump has
gone salted Earth on to santis because
he wants to be president again and
that's just fine but he's done it
through lies and these polls are just
complete nonsense and there is a month
we basically when's the Iowa caucus I
think it might be a month from today is
it January 7th if I'm not mistaken it's
the nth there's basically a month and
and in a way it's less than a month
because we got Christmas week and things
shut down and people don't want to be
thinking about politics the entire time
uh but if that Iowa thing goes
differently than the 50o polls prove and
if Kim Reynolds who's the governor there
is able to help get to santis over the
hump then we have like four days before
New Hampshire South Carolina Etc and
maybe maybe there's a chance to fix all
this I'm a dreamer but I'm not the only
one anyway let me tell to you guys about
enhanced health and then we'll get to
some questions from you guys uh I know
that you my audience is a non-nonsense
crew and so are the guys over at we
enhance health health insurance might
not be the hottest topic but let's face
it it's crucial that's why enhance
health is here to cut through the noise
they get you qualified we're talking
zero premiums on health insurance for
most people we speak to because why pay
more when you can pay none dial 1866 979
1349 and their straightforward experts
will guide you through it no fluff just
facts Health shouldn't be on the back
burner it's time to make it a priority
let's not talk about it people let's do
it enhance Health where your health
needs meet your health terms call 1866
97913 49 and now back to me all right
Ruben report. locals.com Community Q&A
we also have a couple questions in from
Twitter today uh locals was going under
some maintenance management so our push
notifications weren't going out so this
is the first time I've ever asked for
questions on Twitter as well so we're
going to mix it up with a little bit of
both uh Mila says have you gained more
friends or lost more friends since your
commentary on the October 7th attack you
know it's interesting my my opinions are
fairly well known people know what I
think about things uh so I don't know
that I have lost any friends since then
right I don't think it's surprising to
anyone that I'm defending Israel the way
that I am and defending American values
the way that I am and all of that sort
of stuff I think maybe some people have
been maybe impressed or or a little bit
shocked to know that I knew so much
about the area and understand the
geography and the history and all of
those things uh so I don't think that
I've lost any friends although I suppose
it's possible I've lost some and they
just haven't texted me about it uh I
don't know about gaining new friends but
I can tell you that I've received a
whole bunch of text messages and I've
got messages through my parents and
cousins and friends that people that
have not watched my show in a while or
thought I went off the deep end or I
voted for Trump or blah blah that
they're suddenly like oh maybe Dave was
kind of right about what's going on with
the left and the Democrats and how
intersectionality was going to be really
really bad for the Jews and for America
and all of those things and that they're
really was a problem on college campuses
and it was worth talking about all those
years so you know I I've got enough
friends I'm not I'm actually not looking
for new friends at the moment I've had a
nice core group of friends and and my
best two friends on this Earth uh one of
them my buddy John is is moving to
Florida right now and we met on when we
were four years old first day of
kindergarten 1980 uh and another one my
buddy arry we met in third grade so I
I've had the you know I think that's a
testament to uh when you meet somebody
and you're like do how you know tell me
about your friends like you have people
from back in the day I think that's a
good Testament to uh to being a decent
and consistent person so I don't need
new friends but it is nice to get
respect to people uh respect from people
who maybe had lost it over the years
wolf says what do you think are the
motives of open border Democrats on the
right lots of people say they hate
America and they want chaos but that
can't apply to all of them do they think
they are being charitable or see it as a
moral imperative how do they explain it
to themselves I think there's a couple
versions of this so one is I think there
are a set there are a set of Democrats
and lefties and politicians who actually
do want chaos because the more chaos
that there is the more that we will want
authoritarian leaders and Democrats tend
to be more authoritarian so they're
there it's a very very cynical and
Dangerous Game create Chaos on the
streets so that they will see how they
need us right it's that line uh from
Chancellor suler in vper Vendetta we
need to make sure they know how much
they need us so there's a little bit of
that I think then mostly what it is with
like the average Democrat is they just
don't understand what the issues are and
they're blue pilled and they watch CNN
where they don't see the footage that we
show you all the time about the people
flooding the Border they don't make the
connection between saying oh well you
know we're we kind of have an open
border they just don't realize that that
means people are coming in I think the
other thing is that and this is probably
the biggest one a lot of Lefty
Progressive these these Elite types they
want to feel good when they go to
cocktail parties and they have enough
money that a lot of the stuff doesn't
affect them and that's why the the
Martha's Vineyard thing that Des santis
referenced earlier was so interesting
because every day now you can go down to
the Border towns in Texas or or it's
really hitting Arizona right now with
these floods of people coming in and
nobody cares no I mean you know what I
mean like at a mainstream level nobody
cares these these towns are overrun I
think it was the uh was it the El Paso
Airport that the illegals took over
there's some airport down there it's
like it's just ignored because the
liberal Elites don't live down there
then when DeSantis sends what was it 25
people up to Martha's Vineyard all hell
breaks loose for four for four days
right and suddenly they do believe in
Porters and suddenly they don't believe
in Sanctuary cities and everything else
so it's their Elite mindset also and
then I think another version is if you
let enough people in and then you give
them enough stuff eventually they will
become Democrats and you will solidify
your power so it's a lot of things at
once uh a music says how does it feel
after building a successful career in
what you love to do um it feels pretty
damn great truly I I wake up every day I
am doing what I'm supposed to be doing
I'm working with the people I'm supposed
to be working with um it has afforded me
the things in my life that that I want
at a material Level like I don't there's
not I don't really want anything else
majorly I'd like to get a nice cold
plunge put in the backyard that that
would be a nice one um but like I have
the things that I want um I I eat good
food I'm around people that I love and
and I do feel it was a long journey when
when we got to La back in 2013 we had
maybe and I think I'm exaggerating maybe
four or five grand between the two of us
we nothing and we left La you know a
couple years back it'll be two years
next week we left La having made it you
know and that's the whole purpose of
what La used to be you go there to
accomplish the dream and we did it and
now I live in a place that's in line
with my beliefs and I'm every day uh I
fight for what I believe in and I live
in a community that feels like the right
Community live in and and it feels very
and even building locals and then
ultimately emerging with Rumble it was
like I kept saying to people when we
were going into these meetings to raise
money like I was very upfront I was like
I I don't think this is the most
incredible idea like I think it's fairly
obvious that we should build this thing
we're just doing it and everyone kind of
agreed with me I'd go into these
meetings I'd walk out of meetings and I
would say to my business partner I I
don't understand everyone agrees this is
a good idea like isn't that a little odd
and of course it turned out to be a good
idea and it was only because I just took
the issues that I was dealing with on
the show related to free speech and
everything else and I was like let's
build something and we built and it
worked and and then there was obviously
Financial rewards for that so yes it
does it does feel pretty good I guess I
don't think about it that often because
when you're just living your life you're
just living your life but thanks for the
question dump Trump says what would you
Peg the odds of a Newsome Michelle Obama
ticket being well first off I think Nome
took a real hit in some ways that hanity
debate that he did with d santis was a
real test for him because you know
everyone can say you know look Bill Mah
said the exact same same thing to me
that Trump said to Hannity Nome slick
and they say it as if it's good bill Mah
was saying well he's slick you know and
okay well why do we like slick people
Trump kind of was like he's slick he
doesn't have the facts but he's slick
like I like him he smiles again the suit
fits like okay congratulations go go be
a slick used car salesman not the
governor of California or the president
of the United States but I think he did
so poorly that the powers that be in the
DNC have to be re-evaluating that they
have to be re-evaluating I think he
still wants in I think he would be
freaking thrilled if Joe Biden fell down
the stairs today and they had to figure
out the maneuver to move Kamala out and
then get uh new in um Michelle Obama I
you know I know a lot of people there's
like a lot of rumors about that sort of
thing but to me what Obama's doing right
now which is basically running this
Administration from behind the scenes
which is something that he said he would
want to do one day to not be president
uh but if he could just pull the strings
I think that's what what's really going
on here this is just the third Obama
term so I don't even know that you need
Michelle out there also you just have to
like technically like how would you get
Cala out of the way so if Biden falls
down the stairs right now as I'm talking
Kamala becomes president right I've
called her Kamala and Kamala see I'm
doing best I can I want to be respectful
of our very wise uh African-American
female vice president great gal who
celebrates Quanza um how do you
technically get her to move like you'd
have to figure you have to offer her
something and she'd have to step down
and like it's just a whole bunch of
stuff but I don't put anything past
these people they are evil Dan says
how's Dad how's Dad life been recently
really great actually you know now that
they're about 16 months and 14 months
you know I can throw them around a
little bit more like especially Justin
he's just a mad man he's climbing all
over everything Luke is much more like
looking at you trying to figure you out
and figure out what's going on like you
can already see it's it's a fun thing
seeing how they're they're just wired a
certain way from birth and then you know
you can fill them up with with as many
good things as possible and try to get
them to to like the things you like and
all that kind of stuff uh I'm trying to
play basketball with them a little bit
we got a little basketball uh little
hoop that we put in the backyard we we
just built this little fence thing so
that we can just kind of throw them out
there because they're just they they
want to be out and about and doing
things and there's a great video uh
maybe we'll show it next week um of
Jordan Peterson talking about how you
know there's so many kids now that are
just told that they have uh
hyperactivity disorder ADHD all of these
things and it's because we put them in
these schools we sit them down they want
to move they want to run they want to he
says something like you know at the end
of the day that kid should fall into
that bed and just be basically
unconscious because they're exhausted
they have done everything they can do so
that's really what we try to do with
them every day so when I'm in this
studio obviously I can't do it but I
every day I between shows I jump out
there I try to run around with them and
yeah it's good it's good uh McKenzie
says why does it seem people ignore or
are ignorant of the historical context
in the Palestinian Israeli relationship
they ignore the Iron Dome uh the five
attempts SL offers from Israel for a
two-state solution Palestinians can work
in Israel Etc well I think there's many
reasons people ignore it it's partly
that generally speaking our our uh
education system has just failed people
failed people on basic history and facts
I think it's also because that we have
just allow we have seated that ground
and allowed leftists to take over the
institutions and take over the es and
all of those things um like the fact
that there has never been a Palestinian
state for a people known as Palestinians
there was no there were no people known
as Palestinians meaning a Palestinian
Muslim Arab people did not exist until
the 60s when it when it coalesced around
the idea basically of taking out all of
the Jews the British mandate for
Palestine which
existed um was a place where the Jews
lived the Palestine post which is now
the Jerusalem Post was the Jewish
newspaper the Palestinian national
soccer team in the 1920s was founded by
a Jew and it was mostly Jews who played
on it all of these things or we can go
back to the Ottoman Empire before that
and we can go back to the Judean Empire
thousands of years ago or the very story
of Hanukkah that is being celebrated
today um but but people unfortunately do
not know things and um and they have
been radicalized we I guess maybe I
guess maybe even me did not realize the
level of radicalization that the
colleges were doing we all kind of
thought they were making people stupid
and confused and whatever um but the
level of like truly chanting for
genocide and pretending that it's okay
no matter what your political um no
matter your grievance it's still not
okay to burn people alive and rape women
no matter what no matter how just your
cause may be and the Palestinian cause
is not just and certainly the Hamas
cause is not just at all uh but it's a
damn shame and we have a lot of work to
do uh Chris says what's your favorite
Cuban dish personally I love me some
vakka Frita you know I enjoy going down
to Little Havana over here and uh I I
would say the Cuban sandwich but I guess
that's like the easiest thing to say but
a nice mojito of course I enjoy the
Mojito uh what else what else is panin
what is it what is it P panon lein panon
lein Phoenix likes the pan con lein but
a good Cuban sandwich just like just
great uh Siggy says what was the most
helpful thing to your personal life
Andor career that you learned by working
with Jordan Peterson on his tour um well
I mean he kind of pushed me into having
kids that was one thing but I I will say
another thing related to fatherhood and
and Jordan um that you know there's a
line that he says all the time about
that when you have kids it is your
opportunity to have the best
relationship you can with another human
being and I see that very clearly with
these kids like when I get up in the
morning and I immediately go to them and
I have my morning coffee with them and
like they just they're so open and alive
and they look at you with such freaking
joy and happiness and if you think man
if I can just you know like they think
I'm like the greatest thing on earth and
it's like I'm I'm not the greatest thing
on Earth but if I can do everything
possible to be that for them for as long
as possible uh they will probably live a
good life and we will have a great
relationship so that's I think that's
what the challenge is and makes you want
to be a better person I think that
that's the it's cliche it sounds silly
but I think that that maybe is the um
not the greatest benefit of being a
parent but like it's the most unspoken
thing about being a parent that if you
are doing it right it forces you to be
better as a person because you have to
do it ju for somebody else not just for
yourself and that that's good uh Jay
says uh we get why you're a Ron Guy Des
santis uh obviously policies and record
I'm not necess necessarily asking about
you but do you know many that are
supporting Trump that know that know
he's not great he's not a great choice
but for varying reasons uh need to stick
with him no names um it's a good
question and I will try not I'll try not
to do it with names but I would say out
of the pundit class of people like I had
I don't think I've ever said this on
camera I'm just going to go ahead and
say I had one of the top five like major
famous uh political Trump people does
not matter what his or her name is at my
house like seven months ago talking
about how much they wanted run and how
is his time and blah blah blah and that
they didn't want Trump to run and it was
too late and he's too old and there's
too much drama but now is like firmly
back in Trump camp and I think what
happens there and this is what I was
trying to talk about at top of the show
everyone knows D santis is good and he's
telling the truth it's just not going to
get better than this I think everyone
knows that in their heart you may not
agree with every policy right but you
know like this is the guy and that the
only way we can get out of this
political muck is with someone who is
telling the truth and who is fighting
the right fights and there is no drama
it's the only way out it's the only way
out um but I think what happens with a
lot of the pundit class is people start
chasing clicks for one reason or another
it might be because you want the views
because you want the the money uh that
comes with that it might be because
there's a there's like a certain set of
people that just want to chase energy
right like and the truth is the
energy is behind the Trump thing meaning
that the viral of it the ah he said this
everyone goes crazy blah blah blah and
that is something like that that says
something about all of us on on the
inside I know I've lost some viewers uh
by supporting disantis the way I have um
I love it when people are like Ruben
must be getting paid by the disantis
people I've never been paid by the
disantis people or any other candidate
and I would never take money um from a
candidate or a campaign I absolutely
never would I've been the most public
person probably in the entire country on
the journey from from Milan toins from
California to Florida my life is better
because of the Florida stuff you guys
know all that so I've done this because
I'm fighting for what I think is right
in the country um even now like backing
a guy who's so supposedly 50 points down
like what kind of idiot would I be but
I'm doing what I think is right and if
it doesn't work out I will have my
Integrity intact and I will do a show
the next day and and it will it will be
a shame for the country uh but I'll know
that I did the right thing and I think
there's a lot of other people that are
just like they're just in it it's a
thing it's a celebrity related thing
it's it's a thing and uh well let's just
hope that things work out best for
everybody Mary says why do wealthy
Jewish IV donors and obsequious
self-hating whites who get no thanks or
good results from their graveling prefer
wishful thinking to reality is it a
problem of wealthy civilized cultures
you know that's an interesting question
it's sort of related to the earlier
question about immigration why do these
Democrats vote for these things that
destroy things I think there's a there's
a lot of reasons related to it I think
most of it is people don't we're it's we
suffer from the goodness of modernity
for the most part if you live in the
United States or largely in the west our
lives are so good and we all have phones
and food that can be delivered to us and
we have distractions of video games or
you you can go out on the street and
there generally isn't sectarian violence
although it might be on the way like
things basically work and when things
basically work good times create weak
men and then these weak men they start
Al They it's on their watch that the
system starts to fail and then that
creates bad times and then those bad
times of course in turn create strong
men but we would prefer not to go into
the bad times and it does seem like we
are veering into that when you see
everything that's happening on the
college campuses and on these streets
and the calls for genocide and all this
it's like what what reason like we're
all watching it like well this shouldn't
be but what reason do we have to believe
that it will stop I don't know I don't
know I really don't know I don't see a
reason that anyone's going to stop it in
New York City what would stop them from
every day they will just Rampage through
New York City every day they will
Rampage through Chicago who's going to
stop the gun violence in Chicago like
there's no reason to think any of these
things will stop in certain places and
then there are other places Florida
Texas blah blah blah that they will do
things right and I think my suspicion is
that if it is not the santis Trump
unfortunately is just not going to make
things better they will do everything
they can to make sure that that doesn't
happen he most likely will not become
president anyway because there's just
not enough upside on him at this point
and if it's if it is Biden or whoever
else they will clearly make things worse
and I think what will happen is the
remaining sane people in whatever red
States they live in not that they're
going to pull a separatist move like in
the prequels of Star Wars but it will
just become clearer and clearer I think
for me on the show it will become
clearer and clearer that the national
project is infected it's infected we did
everything we could we sent that our
best guy it didn't work okay fine and
now we have to focus at home and you
will have to focus much more at a local
level and that's probably actually
healthy but we shall see and I think
there is a chance to avoid that uh fryed
says how do we try to reform more good
liberals who've been duped by their own
OS into tacitly complying with
authoritarians seem like many just want
to hide in their wealth and ignorance
there's definitely been a theme to the
to the questions today I would say with
that one the best you can do is calmly
explain things to them I know they
usually don't grant you that Grace and
they'll for too long have called
everyone racists and bigots and
everything else that's one of the great
tactics that the left used all these
years was by calling everybody bigots
and racists and homophobes and
transphobes you basically put everybody
in like a Russian Roulette situation or
you could picture like 10 people and
everyone's holding a gun to someone
else's head and they're all standing in
a circle and everyone's like well who's
going to pull first and it's kind of
like oh I better pull first because I
don't want to be the one shot so I
better start getting this thing going
and it's like that's kind of what
they've done when you've called
everybody bigots and racists it kind of
keeps everybody in this in this strange
hostage situation so what happens with a
lot of lefties I've seen this I've seen
this we had a we had a a friend of
David's who's a lifelong Lefty uh came
to the house about a week or so ago with
uh with her son and she was kind of like
Dave I I get what's going on here now
what what you've been talking about I
kind of get it and she's kind of nervous
about it and I gave her a copy of my
book and I said read this and I'm I'd be
happy to talk to you about it further if
you disagree on anything or whatever but
they know that if they walk if they walk
if they leave the left that the same
tactics will be used against them and
it's not fun to be called a racist or a
bigot or anything else but but you just
must be brave enough to walk into the
uncanny valley you have to be brave
enough to walk through the fire you have
to do it you have to do it because once
you see the thing and an awful lot of
people are seeing it right now once you
see it you cannot unsee it I guess you
could get a labotomy that's your best
chance otherwise you cannot unsee it and
you have to walk you have to walk and
you have to go to greener pastures and
they do exist if you want to find them
Anna says what advice would you give to
someone who wants to build a media
platform but doesn't know to start well
whatever it is that you want to do
whatever it is that you want to create
just start doing it you don't have to go
to conferences to learn how to do it you
don't have to give anyone money to teach
you how to do it whatever you do what
you make jewelry you talk about politics
you're an unboxer you're a video gamer
you're a whatever it is that you do go
out there and start doing it and do not
worry about the numbers eventually it'll
come around like if you do something
good eventually people will start seeing
it you might do it for 4 months and the
only person who sees it is your mom and
your and your cousin uh but over time if
you are doing something good eventually
people will see it and then you start
getting some more views and then the
algorithm starts noticing and then
there's a little more attention and then
you go boy I made 50 bucks this month on
ads and then the next month you go wow I
made 250 bucks this month and how can I
learn this connect with people uh but
just I mean I'm freaking on a Nike
commercial just do it just do it really
uh hold the line or hold the wire says
what are the realistic Chan is that
Ronda santis gets the GOP nomination
look I am as I always say I am a world
weary Optimist I do believe it can
happen I truly do I have never seen a
situation where one guy has said I don't
have to debate I can constantly lie
about this guy and and I don't have to
show up and look at these polls and I've
told you how ridiculous the polls are I
really believe that if he wins Iowa
there will be a little window where
people will be like oh there is a little
blood in the water as it relates to
Trump right it's he's not totally
impervious and then I think it will give
an awful lot of people the juice
wherever they are in New Hampshire or
South Carolina or whatever after that to
go you know what I don't know if the
santis is going to win but I am going to
vote for him I do think he's the better
choice and maybe I'm not going to tell
everybody that that's what I'm doing
because I don't want to upset my trump
friends and my trump family uh because
they won't take it nicely just kind of
like the leftists won't take it nicely
when you walk from them but I think if
everyone just makes the choice in their
own mind because I keep hearing the same
thing from people and I get it the
people that come up to me it's a little
self- selected but everywhere I go I
hear the same thing I appreciated Trump
I've had it with the drama I don't like
the way he's campaigned and not debated
and everything else I love D santis but
can it happen so Trump did an incredible
thing and the mainstream media did it
with him they worked together on this
could you make it so that a whole bunch
of people would be like oh that guy
who's obviously the best candidate he
just doesn't have any shot does he and
that's why for weeks Trump's been
screaming that the santis has to drop
out and everything else and it's like no
let's let the people vote otherwise we
will never have debates again now Trump
has said a terrible precedent with this
debate thing because Biden will not
debate Trump let's say Trump had his
reasons he didn't want to debate now I
think it's because he doesn't want to
defend his record and I think seeing a a
competent DeSantis go against him and
call out the to his face which
everyone seems to be afraid to do uh I
think he was afraid of that uh but he
said it was because of the polls and he
didn't have to do it okay well Biden
will have his reasons not to debate I'm
not going to debate Trump he's an
insurrectionist he's he's uh got these
cases going against him I'm not going to
debate him and then congratulations we
will no longer have debates and you
might think the debates are ridiculous
and silly and an often times they are
but if we have no debates and if we
actually why should we even have
elections because there are polls and
polls are good and polls are just and
this poll says this guy's up 50 let's
just we're going to cancel a debate
we'll cancel the election then we have
one leader forever does that seem like a
good idea I don't think so so I don't
know what I'm not going to give you a
percentage of what I think desantis's
chances are but I I think he can win
this but all of us need to do the right
thing and you need to tell your friends
why you're doing the right thing and
everything else that is the chance uh
harpocrates says I'm a former
Progressive all right welcome aboard
that was basically forced out of the
Democrat Party because of the
overwhelming stream of woke nonsense
anti-white and pro Hamas supporters oh
wow so you're you're new uh do you
foresee more of this and with Trump on
the other end are the Republicans
missing a moment
yes can we send this guy something let's
find this guy what was his name
email all right email us contact Ruben
Report with your with your name so that
I can I'm going to sign something for
you and send it welcome aboard um yes
yes yes yes and yes yes yes is the
answer but I'll elaborate just a bit
more um there is a moment right now
because so many decent Liberals are
breaking and this is this is the group
of people that I've been saying for
years was the was the one group of
people in America that could really
break right right you've got the
hardcore Trump people fine you've got
the hardcore crazy communist woke
leftists fine then you have some
moderates here and some moderates here
those all of those people whether you
consider the moderate conservatives or
moderate liberals they're all in that
sort of like we like America we're not
kind of crazy we can agree to disagree
blah blah blah those are the people who
are all up for grabs most of those
people happen to be the Liberals right
now right because the left has gone so
bananas those people would vote for
DeSantis a lot of them cannot vote for
Trump I have heard this a million times
it is not just nor right nor fair the
the way that too many people have Trump
derangement syndrome but the fact is
they do have it and they will not vote
for him no matter what and they don't
want to go through all the stuff again
fine you can judge them for it and
everything else but there is this other
guy who just w a freaking Landslide
reelection here who every if if it
wasn't for Trump running now everybody
would be like this is the greatest
candidate we've ever had we are the most
unified party we've ever uh had we are
going to destroy the wokers and the guy
with dementia and everything else and it
would be obvious and great and all of
that stuff and we all freaking know it
have I made my case
today you want to have lunch do it I'm
gonna go have lunch we got a postgame
show in just a second before I have
lunch at Ruben report. locals.com clip
one of my interview with biologist uh
Brett Weinstein old friend and biologist
Brett Weinstein is up the full thing on
locals already we've got a new Twitter
account for the show it's Ruben report
show Dave ruin. stores where you can get
all your can we put it there
again it's it
here there we go Dave ruin. stor is
where you can get some stuff for the
family for the holidays again I wish uh
those who are celebrating the Hebrews
out there a happy night one of Hanukkah
again it is the ancient story of the
Jews those pesky Jews defending Judea
which is also where Jesus was from
that's Israel uh from the Greek Invaders
those are the bad guys it was the Jews
to okay you got it I leave you with Joe
Biden let's see let me start off with
two
words made in
America made in
[Applause]
[Music]
America
uh post game here we go I want to just
quickly address that there have been